There's that song again. Settle in by the water, little ones. Now — I want to ask you something. When you want a thing to GROW — and it's taking its sweet time about it — does pushing on it make it come any faster? Or is there a kind of work that's really just... waiting? Listen. The answer is in the story.
Now — this happened on a bright, soft morning in spring. Ranger Ray had turned over a patch of warm earth by the meadow, and out of it, the first little green shoots of a garden were just beginning to come up. And one small, fast somebody had decided that the garden was simply growing too SLOWLY. Listen —
Day THREE and these shoots are still just... shoots! No flowers, no buds, nothing! Come ON, garden — we are BEHIND schedule!
That's Zippy. The garden was growing exactly the way a garden grows — slowly, quietly, on the clock God set for it. Zippy could not stand it. So she decided to make it go faster.
And zipping in three places at once, faster than the eye could follow, came Zippy the hummingbird. She hovered over the little garden bed and squeaked,
Wait — wait — I just had SEVEN ideas! Idea one: what if the garden is slow because nobody is CHEERING for it? Idea two: what if it just needs a little... pep talk? Idea three through seven: also cheering, but LOUDER.
And slow and steady, came Shelly the tortoise — young Shelly, sharp of thought though slow of step. She looked at the little green shoots a long, comfortable moment, and said,
...They look right on time to me. Shoots first. Buds later. Flowers when they're ready. ...You can't rush a green thing, Zippy. It grows on its own clock.
Its own clock? Oh, no — I have a FASTER clock! I am the fastest thing at the whole Creek. I beat my wings fifty times a SECOND, Shelly. If anyone can make a garden hurry, it's ME.
...You can beat your wings fifty times a second. ...A bud opens about once.
Right, but it'll open BETTER with me here! Faster, brighter, more petals, possibly in a nicer color — I have not worked out the color part yet, but I'm CONFIDENT.
Then I'll just have to be there for ALL of it! Step one: a breeze machine, to push the growing along. Watch — wings to full power, and... FAN!
...You're fanning a vegetable.
I am COACHING a vegetable, Shelly, there's a difference! A coach BELIEVES. ...Grow, you magnificent little guy! Grow for ZIPPY!
...It's a turnip.
And from the big old oak, all bright feathers, called down Garingo the parrot —
BEHOLD! The hummingbird races the SEASON itself! A contest for the ages! ...My feathers are with you, small warrior. I shall narrate from a comfortable distance. Someone must.
And at the edge of the meadow stood Fern the fawn, watching the little garden with her soft eyes. She said, quiet but clear —
I noticed something. ...There's a bud, right in the middle. Closed up tight. It wasn't there yesterday. ...Maybe watch that one. Gently, though.
A bud! A CLOSED bud! Perfect — that's my finish line. Garden, meet your coach. We are going to open that bud by LUNCH. Right — Plan A: the breeze machine. Fanning... now!
And Zippy beat her wings into a little wind over the garden bed, harder and harder, until the leaves were bending flat. And the bud... did what buds do in a hard wind. Listen.
...Zippy. The bud's closing TIGHTER. ...That's what they do when the weather turns rough. You made it a storm.
Tighter?! It's supposed to go the OTHER way! Okay — okay — fanning was Plan A. Scrap Plan A. Plan B: I'll SING it open! Flowers love a good song, everybody knows that. Ahem — riiise and shiiine, little buddy —
And Zippy sang to the bud. She sang it a morning song, and a marching song, and a song she made up on the spot about being a flower. The bud... was a bud. It did not move at all.
...That third song had a key change.
Thank you! At least SOMEBODY liked my singing! The bud did NOT. The bud has no ear for music at ALL.
Nothing! I gave it my BEST flower song! Fine. Plan C: I will hover RIGHT over it and just... be here. The whole time. Watching. Cheering it on. It can't grow slow with me STARING at it.
BEHOLD — the staring contest between a hummingbird and a VEGETABLE! ...I confess I do not know who is winning. ...It may be the vegetable.
It is NOT winning! ...okay it might be winning. Shelly — why isn't ANY of this working?! I am the fastest, hardest-working creature in the meadow and that bud is just... ignoring me!
...Because it isn't a race, Zippy. ...You've been trying to win. The bud's just... living. The two things have nothing to do with each other.
Now, just then, a cloud slid off the sun, and the whole little garden went warm and gold. And Shelly did a thing Zippy never thought to do. She didn't speed up. She slowed all the way down. She put one slow foot in the warm dirt, and she got comfortable. Like she had all day. Because she did.
...Sun's out. Ground's warm. ...This is the part the bud's been waiting for, Zippy. Not the fanning. Not the songs. This. ...Come sit in it.
Sit in it? I don't SIT, Shelly, I'm a hummingbird, if I stop I fall out of the sky — okay — okay. New plan. The BIGGEST plan. What if I build a growth-acceleration machine, out of reeds, and a warm rock, and one of Garingo's dramatic feathers, and I aim the whole MORNING right at this one bud —
BEHOLD — a MACHINE! ...You want my dramatic feather for a SPRINKLER? ...It is a feather of GREAT theatrical importance. ...Oh, very well. Take the one I use for villains.
Perfect! I shall call it... the Bloom-o-Matic! It has a warm rock, a feather, three reeds, and a little ramp — I don't know what the ramp does yet, but every good machine has a ramp!
...The ramp is fine, Zippy. ...None of it makes a flower hurry.
...Zippy. The reeds are fine. ...Look at the bud right now. Up close. Not to fix it. Just look.
...Okay. Fine. Looking. ...Huh. There's a tiny crack down the side. Like a green seam. It IS opening — just... so slow I couldn't see it. It's been opening the whole time I was fanning and singing and STARING.
Wait — if it's already opening on its OWN... then maybe I can just help it the last little bit. Here — I'll be SO gentle — I'll just tuck my beak in the seam and ease it —
...Zippy. Stop. ...Stop. ...Pull your beak back. Slow. ...There. ...Look at the petal.
...There's a little white line. On the edge. ...I almost tore it. I almost ripped the petal trying to make it open faster. ...It was going to open ANYWAY. And I nearly broke it being in a hurry.
...Yeah. ...You can pull a bud open with your beak. But then it isn't a flower anymore. It's just a torn thing you were in too much of a hurry to wait for. ...That's the whole trouble with hurrying a living thing. God grows it on God's own clock — and that clock is gentler than ours.
...I can make a hundred things go faster. I can fly faster, think faster, build faster than anybody. ...And I could not make ONE bud grow faster. Not by an inch. Not by a SECOND.
I tried SO hard. I fanned it and sang to it and stared at it all morning. And the only thing my trying did... was nearly tear it. The harder I worked, the closer I came to wrecking the one thing I wanted.
And Shelly came and sat down in the warm dirt right beside her, slow as anything, and didn't say a word. She just sat. And after a while, I leaned in close, and I asked Zippy the one thing I most wanted to know.
...Zippy. All that racing... all that hurry... what was the garden really waiting on, the whole time — if it wasn't you?
...The sun. ...And the rain. And the warm dirt. And just... time. ...The slow stuff. The stuff I can't speed up and can't build and can't beat. ...God set the season, and the garden was waiting on the SEASON. Not on me.
My job was never the hurrying. My job was the WATERING. ...I can carry water. I can keep the weeds off. I can give it sun and then... let it be. ...Huh. Turns out the fastest creature in the meadow has a SLOW setting after all. I just never built one.
...I'll get there. I always do. ...Turns out the bud will too. ...It just doesn't need a coach. It needs a friend who'll wait with it.
And do you know what they did? They stopped racing the garden. Zippy carried water from the creek, drop by careful drop. She nipped the little weeds away. She gave the bud the sun, and then — the hardest thing she'd ever done — she let it be. And she did NOT watch it all night.
And the next morning, before Zippy was even awake — quiet, with nobody fanning it and nobody singing to it and nobody staring — the bud opened all the way. A little purple flower, wide to the sun. And back at the oak, who was waiting? Garingo — and Fern.
BEHOLD — the flower has OPENED! And the hummingbird... was ASLEEP for the victory! ...You raced the season for three days and WON by taking a nap?! ...Magnificent. I shall write a ballad. It will be slow.
It's the prettiest one in the whole bed, Garingo. ...And look — it opened the same morning you stopped trying to make it. ...Maybe that was the trick all along. You did your part. Then you trusted it.
...I missed it open. The one thing I worked three days for, and I was ASLEEP when it happened. ...And you know what? That's exactly right. It was never my moment to win. It was the flower's moment to be ready. ...I just got to be there for the after.
Now, that little purple flower, opening all by itself in the morning, put me in mind of something. There's a line in the Bible — in a book called James, chapter five, verse seven — a letter a man named James wrote to a group of friends who were finding it hard to wait.
And to tell them what waiting really looks like, James didn't point to anyone rushing. He pointed to a FARMER — somebody who plants a seed and then can't do one single thing to hurry it up. He wrote:
Behold, the husbandman waiteth for the precious fruit of the earth, and hath long patience for it, until he receive the early and latter rain.
A husbandman — that's just an old word for a farmer, little ones. And the farmer does his part: he plants, he waters, he keeps the ground. And then he WAITS, with long patience, for the rain and the sun to do what only they can do. He can't pull the fruit up faster. Nobody can.
That's the way of it. The growing was never your job. The TENDING was. You do your small part — the water, the weeds, the sun — and then you trust the season God set, and you wait. The slow does the rest.
Until the next breeze brings us together, my friends. Be patient out there, little ones. Do your part — then let the slow things take their own sweet time.
And from his lecture branch swooped Professor Hoot, the most certain owl in Shiloh Creek. He cleared his throat — and announced,
Professor Hoot here, with a fact that is completely true — and tied, you'll be glad to hear, to all that WAITING our young friends did today. Here it is: inside a robin's egg, a tiny bird is growing — and you cannot hurry it. Not one bit.
The mother robin sits on her little blue eggs and keeps them warm — for about two whole weeks. There is even a grand word for it: to incubate.
What does that splendid word mean? It only means this: to keep an egg warm, and wait, while the little one inside grows on its own. Warm it, and wait. That is the whole job.
And here is the wonder of it, children. All the growing happens INSIDE the shell, where no one can see it, on a clock entirely its own. You cannot peek. You cannot help. And you most certainly cannot crack it open early — for the little one is not yet ready.
When the chick IS ready — and only then — it taps its own way out, all by itself. Warm it, and wait. That is all anyone can do. A fact, true and tested. Good evening.
And up from the mud-edge hopped the Mudpuppy brothers — Splish, Splash, and Splosh — already mid-argument. Splosh banged the table,
Today on Mudpuppy Minutes, we will explain... why a CATERPILLAR has SO many legs!
Simple. A caterpillar has so many legs because it kept FINDING them. Lying about. A spare leg here, a spare leg there — well, you don't just leave a good leg on the ground. You put it ON.
AND ALSO — ! It's such a LONG, soft, stretchy body, see — so it needs lots of little legs spread all the way down to hold the whole long shape up and walk it along. ...wait. That sounded almost like a real reason.
Oh no, no — that can't be right, that's too SENSIBLE. No. A caterpillar has so many legs because it is actually NINE worms holding hands. In a coat. Pretending to be ONE worm. We've all seen it.
AND ALSO — that is why it walks all WOBBLY! Nine worms, one coat, nobody agreeing which way to go. Left! No, LEFT! It's chaos in there.
Wait — is it actually just... a long body needs lots of legs to hold it up, like Splash said?
...nah.
Mudpuppies, mudpuppies — we have solved it. A caterpillar is NINE worms in one coat, holding hands. Count the legs. Divide by hands. You'll see.
Mm. Let's straighten that one out before you hop off, little ones. A caterpillar has all those little legs because its body is long and soft — so it grows lots of tiny grippers down the whole length to hold itself up and inch along, step by step. It's one creature, not nine. Splash had the right of it, fair and square.
...Though I'll grant you, nine little worms in one shared coat is a far funnier picture. ...I'd not be the one to break it to them.
See you next time... somewhere in Shiloh Creek.